hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my newsletter readers Audrey who wrote
in about asking how she can stand out
from her competition so Sheridan
specifically saying good morning Evan
could you kindly advise us on how does
one make a common product unique when
approaching reputable companies I think
so thanks for the question
something a lot of entrepreneurs will
wrestle with is how to stand out from
their competition it's especially hard
when there's nothing different about
your product compared to everybody else
and the way that you are going to send
out is you know it's not gonna be on the
features because it's the same product
that everybody else is selling but it
shouldn't be more on the service side of
things so how can you provide the
absolute best kind of service to your
clients compared to everybody else so
you can think about you know speed how
fast to get back to customers or
prospects when they contact you by phone
or by email
how much do you try to go above and
beyond to service the needs you know of
your clients can really help them out
this delivery are you giving them you
know timely delivery better than your
competition so you got to think about
the service side how can you make your
customers fall in love with you compared
to your competition a lot of times
companies will have established
suppliers that they use but they may not
you know really be in love with them
they may use them just out of habit so
if you can really come in and wow them
with your service and really go above
and beyond thinking about how you can
help their business beyond just
supplying whatever product it is to them
then you become a really important and
valuable part of their ongoing business
and that becomes really crucial to help
you stand out convert everybody else now
you talked about going up to reputable
companies and how to get established my
favorite favorite favorite way to do it
is to try to start on a really small
project and then over
like crazy so try to find you know you
may have an ideal client that you're
going after and it may be worth a lot of
money to you try to start on a really
small project with them and that project
you may not make a lot of money on I
wouldn't cut my my pricing down too much
but I would spend a lot of time and
effort on the service and the delivery
of whatever product you're producing you
basically want to take one small project
that's really low risk for them so you
can say just try me out we do a really
small order let me prove myself to you
let me show you how we can really wow
you right everybody else and you know
because it's a little risk to them
they're more likely to say yes then you
come in you go crazy on this first order
you know make sure they love you try to
add a couple of other things on the
service side too really wild and
compared to what your competition is
doing and then when it's time to reorder
who are they gonna go with and your your
the company who's really stood out so
they're gonna want to keep coming back
in ordering from you and this is
strategy I use over and over and over
again with my clients I get hired by
corporate clients who asked me to create
content for their websites for example
and they may hire me as well as 50 other
bloggers who are trying to create
content as well and what I do is always
try to go above and beyond the
expectation so you know they ask you 500
words I'll usually create at least a
thousand or 1500 words a lot of video on
top of it I'll then promote it and
market it and show you know my readers
what I'm doing and drive traffic to them
and promote them and give them a lot of
exposure so that my articles end up
getting you know ten times plus the
amount of traffic and comments and with
everybody else
so then when it's time to you know
negotiate an extension they're gonna
come to me first compared to everybody
else because I'm providing a lot of
extra value and that also allows you to
increase your pricing now if your
product is exactly the same then it can
be hard to charge too much of a premium
but if you provide a lot of extra
service then you might be able to
justify charging
higher prices affect your competition
but you got to start off wowing them and
showing them that you can deliver
compared to everybody else from your
market so hopefully that answers your
question if you liked the video and
really appreciate that those are you
watching if you want to look give it a
thumbs up it makes me want to do more
these videos for you and if you have a
comment about this video or you have a
question of your own for your business
you'll feel leave it in the comments
below I always read those and I try to
respond to as many as I can so thank you
and I'll see you on the next episode
you